corbin burns yeah first start for kurt
corbin and back-to-back starts against
the pirates last time out on the 23rd
five in the third five heads three runs
one two for burns and a blow by fastball
takes care of gonzalez for out number
one
and derek holland the left-hander
pitched well last weekend
against milwaukee here is jed jerko 206
with three home runs
says jen jerko pounds one deep into left
field
and that is gone a home run
he went deep on him last weekend he
wastes
no time tonight as the brewers are first
on the board
if you can hit a fastball in you're
going to have some pitches to hit
tonight off of this guy
well you love jeff jerker he's got big
power
hit a bomb in pittsburgh he impressed
with the stuff
with corbin burns executing better and a
swinging miss there
cutter cutter that got him for round
number one good pitch for him his last
time out against pittsburgh
two balls two strikes jt
riddle third baseman tonight for the
pirates
burns bringing it and that is strike
three called
a couple of k's in the inning three
through the first two for corbin burns
we're through an inning and
what happened miller park now the pitch
strike three call beauty didn't lose his
aggressiveness after the jerko home run
mathias fired from cleveland a couple
years ago former
third round pick of the indians and a
called third strike with a fastball
maybe gets a call from john tumpaine
runner takes off on a 1-2 pitch it's a
swing and a miss and
that's strikeout number five for derek
holland
through two innings ron and his career
has
799 extra base hits
singles fine but not a bad time to get
that 800th extra base hit as well
swinging a high fly left field back
frazier
gone three run home run ryan braun
[Music]
800 extra base hits in his career
and it's four nothing brewers yeah good
call partner well done
a line shot out of the ballpark for his
second home run of the season
one-two pitch to newman here it comes
got him
[Applause]
out number two and strikeout number five
nasty slider
and five strikeouts for burns
one and two to count the reynolds
burns deals a swing and a miss they'll
go ahead and secure it the slider taking
care of business
for burns and that's six strikeouts for
him as we are through three and one half
of this series opener four nothing brew
crew this is the
seventh starts in the big leagues for
jacob nottingham he's appeared in nine
games with a big club
and there's a drive hit back in a deep
left field
there it goes it's gone a no
doubter for jacob nottingham
oh the brewer is bringing out the home
run lumber tonight
it's six nothing in the fourth boy that
was a
bomb
[Applause]
i mean i think that went over that
miller sign out there that miller light
sign did it
i'm not sure but it was crushed
three balls two strikes two outs six
nothing the brewers have the lead
mark mathias is the batter and there's a
shot hit
into left field and that's gonna go to
the wall
and the brewers are going to get a
couple out of it here as a throw to the
plate
not in time as mark matthias delivers
[Applause]
garcia are in eight runs tonight
all with two men out yeah just an
amazing and bad for
matthias i mean he really earned that
one finally got a pitch that he liked
this pitch is hammered to deep right
field and jt
riddle clears the deck with a cannonball
into the second deck at miller park
his first pirate home run and the bucks
are on the board and that takes care of
the extra base hit
it's eight to one we've known he
has some pop jt riddle
just hasn't uh gotten on track two balls
no strikes
and there's a fly ball hit back into
left center field
he hit it well it is back and that's the
second of the night
for jed jericho
it's going to be tough to for craig
counts to keep him out of the lineup he
keeps this up
two home runs tonight this one coming
against a right-handed pitcher
one and two to gregory polanco trying to
finish him off and a ground ball
into the shift is there the brewers take
the opener of this four-game
series fun night at the yard tonight